hi my name is Le Jeff and I play annab
Chase I'm Walker scell and I play Percy
Jackson hi I'm Ari and sadre and I play
Grover Underwood we're the cast with
Percy Jackson and we are with BuzzFeed
to take the quiz let me try that again
hi BuzzFeed we're here with Percy
Jackson we're going to be hi guys anyway
um we're the cast of Percy Jackson and
we're here with BuzzFeed to see which
Percy Jackson character we actually are
good job good job took a lot out of
thank you thank
you
choose an activity at Camp AFF sword and
shield practice archery with Chiron
winged horseback riding arts and crafts
climbing wall with the saders and
Capture the Flag I'm going to capture
the flag yeah Capture the Flag includes
like sword and shield practice right
yeah well the wined horse back riding
would be pretty cool yeah Pi a TV show
that was I supposed to PR it yeah I got
so scared like a TV show that is based
on a book to watch tonight Gossip Girl
is based on a book what never seen that
the Vampire
Diaries obviously gos only kiding I'm
going Game of Thrones I think I'd go
game of I've always wanted to see it I
vampire di I choose a different one or
we got are you going to go vampire di
yeah oh yeah we can choose whatever want
we all have to choose ex CH the one I
want use blue food to eat there's blue
cupcake blue Donuts blue ice cream blue
lollipop blue pancakes and blue betties
berries do we have to eat the Getty
Images
too walk I'm going blue P pancakes yeah
I did blueberries blueberries just
blueberries I don't like anything sweet
that's that's insane which Percy Jackson
character would you want to fight
alongside posidon Chiron Hermes Sally
Jackson Zeus and Nest I Zeus I feel like
is the office like are we going off of
Personality or like strength I mean
they're all kind of gods except Kiron
and Sally Jackson I'm going to pick Zeus
I I understand that but also are we
trained or like are we to carry us like
are they going to carry us what are we
fighting there's a lot of variables in
this where we posid like where are we
fighting under the ocean ask too many
questions I'm going to take a fastest
cuz he can like give me something cool
I'm going to go for Poseidon I feel like
cuz he can do earthquakes on ground oh
you're right and he kind of like covers
the entire sea yeah and he's Toby
Stevens so and he's Toby Stevens and
which ancient Greek being are you
fighting Medusa Titans py Ops fairies
hell hounds and minor okay so with
Poseidon I thinka I'm going to go the
furies all three of them yeah I could
take them I don't even need a festas
choose an actor z z Cho Z sorry Z Zena
Margo Robbie Logan lurman Tom Holland IA
Davis and Ryan Reynolds it's between
Margot and and Logan for me I
Z I don't think you guys caught that but
I said by the way I would pick Ryan I
would always pick Ryan but I'm going to
go something different and I'm pick
Logan lurman cuz I watched spks being
wow recently I feel like I feel like
that'd be pretty cool to do something
like that with him I'm going to go
margar Robbie also Pig
Anda and finally pick something
important from the Percy Jackson
Universe ooh these are all really good
anab best's invisible cap rip tree
Thalia tree we can get Thalia tree we
can own that no pick something important
our back Theros of winds clar's electric
spear the Luke's wins okay if in the
Percy Jackson Universe I'm going
but in real life go on luk swing shoes
in real life I'd go annabet invisible
cap what yeah you can fly with Luke
swing shoes and I can go invisible with
annab BET's cap yeah what would I do
with the tree though is it just like in
the backyard yeah I'm just going to take
I'm going to take Luke's Wing
[Music]
Shoes oh nice I got Percy Jackson I got
annab Chase I got Percy Jackson I got
chase this is really fitting this is
this is accurate your personality
matches annab Beth you're smart oh thank
daring and Charming oh thanks like
Annabeth once you set your mind to
something there's nothing and no one who
will stop you from achieving your goals
they got cameras in my house for real oh
sorry sorry that's me that's me guys are
two of your
strong why do they do they always catch
they him very wrong right there guys
your personality matches Percy you're
kind-hearted Brave and sarcastic like
Percy you've overcome a lot in your life
and you've come out on the other side
stronger than ever you're someone people
see as a natural born leader you have a
rebellious Street which means you
sometimes jump into situations head
first at the end of the day you'll
always do anything to protect the people
closest to you a a thank you buz thank
you guys so much
for hey you got man thanks man thank you
BuzzFeed make sure to check out Percy
Jackson and the Olympians on Disney plus
watch it
now watch it now camera oh we got to
take some
photo sorry we're professionals just
give us a second this is awesome are
these stock photos or this is you
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys